la befana è passata quasi e si è
sfracellato per terra
basta questo nuovo gameplay dobbiamo
scappare dalla beata di robles quindi
nuovissima è che i rom lasciate come
stai più bel mi piace fasciato prevedere
altre schifo mettetevi comodi preso i
pop corn iniziamo subito ma prima di
iniziare volevo parlarvi di questo libro
il libro dei guinness world records
2022 se non avete visto il video cui
tentiamo i record più popolari al mondo
del libro guinness corre cortandone
vederlo dopo questo video è un libro
super interessante per i più curiosi con
migliaia di record è un'ottima idea
regalo per i vostri amici vi lascio il
link in descrizione al libro e ora
pronti e
così siamo delle schede brugada befana
pronti per iniziare si no quante volte
si spera accellera abitare ma nessuna
perché ormai sono diventato bravissimo
vincerò io vincerò vitale e ci siamo
subito la locomotiva ma sul treno si
attenta dobbiamo andare una stella ecco
questi sono i calderoni della befana
percorse sbracciato non in vantaggio
tanto ora ti raggiungo dovessero la
befana forse alla fine la incontriamo mi
piace il mio nuovo outfit mio outfit
nella vita reale non queste anche il
prezzo del mio personaggio di rob lowe e
vita sta approfittando della mia
distrazione nuovo superarmi
wow
è un lavoratore di pozione di sul treno
quindi chissà dove sta andando star
andando a casa della befana attento a
non cadere queste pozioni non o prendere
tutta la pelle almeno faccio più fonti
fava perché evitare va così base è
diventato bravo ogni volta superveloce
scriveteci nei commenti voi che festa
preferite natali o la befana non so dove
andare qui lo sai forse bisogna saper
saltare
ma io mi sono sfracellato eppure durante
allora spetta come funzionare le ei
sfracellato
forse da questa parte allora no sui
libri qui l'ho capito perché è passata
una prima
non dovevamo andare delle rotaie diciamo
tante nome gigante superare vitale
almeno sto prendendo tutte le stelline
ragionato e vivono dopo lucci credo che
se già avanti
stiamo già a livello 15 a che strane
skyroom si riuscirà inoltre 9 d ora
siamo davvero se voci arrivati dove
siamo però forse dobbiamo entrare nel
castello della befana che sembra un
pontefice che la befana si cucinerà
nella funzione di una tomba fa aspetta
di dover scappare vitale da che vale
dovremo andare non organizzo o noi la b
ricchi e vanno affatto bene ladri tech
ha detto io avevo quando facevo primo io
allora doppione afa intanto sono avanti
penso sia la strada giusta perché
esistono le mani stelline c'è anche un
altro personaggio più il nostro
giocatore a vita levi ha superato di
roma sbrighiamoci vi ricordate quel
gioco in cui evitare dovevamo fare le
pozioni roma o nell'altro vi lascio poi
il link qui ho qui per vederlo perché
era troppo non puoi creare una
promozione quindi formavamo le altre
persone in qualcos'altro c'era anche la
funzione scoreggia ti ricordi della
funzione ascom regionale preferita di
vietarlo solo quella dai dove la befana
o che bello questo embra tipo una classe
di harry potter
stiamo grancia dentro il castello della
strega allora vedi lampadari con le
candele si
guarda io sono qui ciao
eccomi sono qui vive di gioco
rallenta noti speciale rai
se questa giocatrice che sembra che si
stia guidando usando la knox si è
sfracellato adesso ti vedrai che tira
ter colorati non tanto se usciti
sfracelli sopra però bellissime queste
stanze questi sei io dove sto andando su
delle macchie di olio vitale è entrato
nel labirinto da solo si perderà
sicuramente perché sa benissimo
evitare nella b
no ai già trovata quella sì salute le
bacchette quale nuovo mini la befana è
una strega d amico vedi sembra tutto
sembra tutto stile harry potter
comunque diciamo che evitare una
schiappa nei labirinti si perde sempre
prima di entrare mi segue e li segue me
perché scrive di luigi e intonse si
perdesse aspetto bisogna solo cercato di
lui ha
finalmente superato vitale siamo in
vantaggio allenerò team rosa contro team
arancione usciti fuori dalla casa
sembra che siamo tipo box mid di harry
potter ma in realtà poterono gelati
guarda se iscritto gelati creature
magiche note di bacchette
entrato in quel portale non so dove sono
finito eccoti ci sia che tu o meno una
foresta
quindi sono cappelli vedi sono cappelli
al contrario sacelit e loeb e farne al
contrario vede perché perché dobbiamo
andare io credo che la causa del no no
poi a tardi lati sfracelli fa nel
frattempo vitale mi ha superato esiguo
anzi semmai di lava i miracoli della
strada giusta io mi sono appena
strotolato di qua quindi no
tutti nostro
giornata aspetta mi sono perso non so
dove devo andare adesso devo riuscire a
prendere il badge da vincitore prima io
ho un po ci sono anche le coop è proprio
la nimbus 2000 adoro questo schifo e
caso invitato rovato
sembra che stiamo facendo una gara anche
con questa giocatrice che si sta sempre
a zero anche se lì ci aspetta
debuttato a giugno sono scivolato
e che questa giocatrice mi aspetta che
bravo anche la tua stessa maglietta per
la vive beh io vado già stata saluto
bortone tra il trasporto siamo ancora
fuori all'aperto del peso di quasi
militare e fanno il contrario e mi ha
superato di nuovo aspetto
questo che possono
certo non mi supererà i no
e mi ha spinto giù questo non è giusto
vuol dire che star del team rosa dalla
mia parte ma dove sei tu come hai fatto
a dare lazio e sono scivolato
dobbiamo saltare nelle porzioni adesso
vedi se si mettano sfracellata
a ha
quindi ho capito come funziona da di
pozioni stai attento erano sfracellarsi
per che è perché si sono ricostruiti
porta sfortuna è bella e quanti liquidi
mancano pochi mi sa che devo arrivare
primario non prende il peggio
del castello gonfiabile
cosa abbiamo vinto si è preferito è
arrivato
prima ai 2.000
bar a chi consiglia di scendere dallo
scivolo e super divertente dai sedili
provo quindi
mi sono sfracellato ma cave abbiamo già
vinto il gioco sia stato rapidissimo
prossimo gioco in questo gioco siamo noi
le befane abbiamo dire di rigiocare a
quello delle pozioni però questa è
un'edizione speciale e quindi dobbiamo
vedere cosa c'è di diverso ma waki
wizards è troppo divertente
di trasformare subito vitale non do
allora quegli ingredienti mi sembrano
simili ma anche questa è un'edizione
speciale quindi sicuramente se andiamo a
cercare degli ingredienti troveremo
qualche ingrediente speciale ciò che
vediamo questo numero ricerca
ema e palle di neve sì ma non posso
prenderlo come ingrediente vabbè ma
fatto che lavoravano seguendo perché
meno di zombie qua è strano se non ci
vede però ho trovato un ingrediente
matteo del pericolo gli zombie di ti
tolgono un po di vita di papa paolo vi
stanno inseguendo gay e sono scappata
dalla casa di marzapane perché gli
zombie vi stavano inseguendo io cosa
cercare qualcos'altro
padovana vedi la befana è passata quasi
si è stata celata per terra a trovare
altri ingredienti
ho preso questo wow 4 messo un labirinto
misterioso non sono permesse le pozioni
quindi qua non si possono mai e mi
perdono al labirinto infatti vado io
piace a
voi rubare gli ingredienti sono solo b e
in
questo labirinto è strettissimo non
capisco dove sta andando
e stato il labirinto dove stai andando o
no ho l'impressione che ci perderemo
manette molto facilmente se ho perso io
aiuto ritrovare di gregorio mi sono
perso peggio per te te l'avevo detto di
non entrare nell'abito numero uno come
rino perché non lo so qualcuno che si è
spaventato è rimasto qua vorrei usarlo
mano non mi fai cliccare niente pure il
ragno gigante con una persona
ma che succede
no che se c'è uno che mi ha trasformato
in una pannocchia
non mezzo all'area di vederti se riesco
a
fare una trovato niente quella verità
sono da buttare ma questa è vitale
ti ho portato anche una mozione
bellissima come fanno schiaffi roger ti
somiglia proprio guarda mi devo fidare
bere la botte proviamo dai vediamo
che succede
è perché diventati gaggio kakà si è
fatto diventare molleggiata a io pensavo
invece che mi destina posteriore
correggia come tedio ora la posizione
migliore allora questo non era granché
questa volta non andrò nella b rito
perché non ho trovato nessun ingrediente
per cercare qualcosa di malefico per
vitale diamo se trovo qualcosa in acqua
io ho già preso il bus è già preso
invece di principiante creatore di
pozioni vai la gara non ha fatto nel
sottomura ne ho preso un colore cosa vi
serve a niente io ho trovato questo
ingrediente che è un pesce io ho trovato
una cassaforte invece è mai un regalo
bello però aspettavo vetta prima tu bevi
la via postierla tienila potere
bevilacqua dopo prenderò io e tuo regalo
no prendi prima violenta brevi ma
possiamo inumidito di the baby
prevenendo
non sarà più una pannocchia
tenore chi lo pensa pop e da sorin e
allora chiedo a farfalla
il suo regalo invece che cos'è
non dollaro
ma che bello però passa molesto speranze
scorregge puzzolenti
che cosa sta succedendo aiuta come posso
tornare gioco non voglio rimanere qua in
aria a che pozione meritato ok ho capito
come scendere aspetta vengo a
controllare che cosa hai dove sei
sparito severe guarda
[Risate]
ho fatto la scorrendo così forte che mi
è partito il sedere
è quella che per il futuro beh io vado a
cercare altre
ingredienti per fare apparire federa
vita e
dall'altro di divertente volevo che cosa
trovo passato qualcosa da ciò che cos'è
citiamo
e un tacco un tantino ho preso un
tacchino non so cosa serve basse le cose
da una mozione
con nostri ci sono gli zombie qui sono
arrivati anche a fuoco che ho preso la
pozione vieni e bere la pozione tutti
libere la tua però fieri
ma che vogliono questi zombie ma
lasciatemi in pace dobbiamo bene le
nostre emozioni e
trasformarci dicendo dai beviamo vai
prima tu adesso
che succede perché è noto che
emozione mirato
ok io bevo la via allora quella che
mette tutto vediamo cosa succede
trasformate lo spacchino
[Risate]
si chiamava la portiamo là non mi
ricordo
ok facciamo ora l'ultima pozione però
dobbiamo prima resettare il personaggio
a me piace essere pechino ok allora tu
puoi rimanere tale devo cercare l'ultima
porzione proprietari devo cercare
qualche ingrediente fare cio voglio
andare a cercare nuovi ingredienti
vediamo
se lei
stato che sono finita c'è di colombo ma
che fa il dj e troverò qualche
ingrediente qua a questi possono
comprare calderoni diversi o fama
l'accettano ingredienti
questo darà più tempo a me per cercare
degli ingredienti speciali allora che
bello il tacchino va sott'acqua 76
sott'acqua pesce voleva di
carini il proprio carino da tacchino
o che si trovata degli ingredienti dove
dovuto minore il
peperoncino come questo posto che
mettiamo il nostro gradiente peperoncino
nel calderone però voglio aggiungere
qualcos'altro si aggiungiamo lo re io
gigante lima sapevi che abbiamo il libro
di emozioni
che ti mai scelto io ho scelto team
wizard puoi scegliere maghi e streghe io
vi avete streghe o almeno da questo
libro possiamo capire come fare le
pozioni
investimenti a casa come facciamo noi
abitiamo quanti ingredienti che a questo
giocatore
ecco vitale è che cosa hai combinato che
possono mi stai preparando stazione
orbitale tacchino fa troppo ridere
carino ho preparato per te la pozione
verde preferito va bene allora l'abbiamo
prima io e poi ti do la tua
vediamo cosa farà
cosa hai fatto
campovolo kakà ha attuato una
pozione a bettola tu potevi fare una
porzione del genere ecco che chi va a
parigi alibi ma non lo sono ecco qua io
ho preparato la pozione per te se i
propri sogni dove vai lui e di
sant'agata ecco qua vai che ti fa ok va
bene
sono diventato facile gigante
il progetto fuoco
sto prendendo fuoco ho preso fuoco
melo dovrebbe essere peperoncino che ha
fatto questa festa sono diventato il
tacchino di fuoco invisibile guarda
verdi e la pacca solo invisibile e
rischiano trattazione in borsa
perde parte come ha proposto gioco anche
i wizards è bellissimo ma state un mi
piace mi piace volete vedere un altro
episodio ora vi lascio buco a 4
castellinese puoi cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri vi dilettate su quella che
preferite